normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government first
of all Chris Christie also doesn't know
what provinces in eastern Ukraine he
actually want us to fight
for foreign policy experience Ron is
laughing at that was closing a bridge
from New Jersey to New York so do
everybody a favor just walk yourself off
that stage enjoy a nice meal and get the
hell out of this
right I you're going to actually send
your sons and daughters to go
excuse me Chris I'm speaking and I'm not
done
yet going to be
doneen this is if these people want to
send your sons and daughters to go die
in Ukraine they've been arguing for it
for a year $200 billion of our taxpayer
money sent over neither of them could
even name for you the provinces that
they actually want to protect and this
is the people who have been touting
their so-called foreign policy
experience it is intellectual fraud
these people are lying to you the same
people who told you about weapons and
mass destruction in Iraq to justify that
Invasion didn't know the first thing
about it yet they sent thousands of our
sons and daughter st stop he's already
dead holy
points tril of our naal Deb due to
these toxic
neoc lipti on a is still a fascist
neoc them Mr all over again thank you Mr
ramaswami 15 second gas in the stage
dude wow name the provinces neither you
could let me not Crimea it's not Crimea
that's not the one they're talking about
Flor is CHR all right let me just say
this you know this is the kind of thing
where he talks about experience you know
I was the US attorney in New Jersey when
the terrorist attacks were launched
against the United States in 2001 I
brought the two first two in this
country against terrorists who tried to
attack us again I know about the threat
of terrorism bullying remember 911
argument doesn't work when you have a
large voter base younger voters who were
not were little children or not even
alive MTH at Harvard Marine active duty
guy but like I was fact matter back then
he was a
Democrat remember it was 14 know but
there are actual voters right
now knows how to do is insult good
people who have committed their lives to
public service and not say anything that
moves the ball down the field for the
United States all right thank you
Governor Christie I hate the term Public
Service sorry if if you're elected
official you're
not and that's funny because has been
rushed for a long time that's not what's
in contention right now right right
right and so VI I think he absolutely
nailed them with that question uh which
which provinces do you actually want to
defend oblasts administrative regions
and they're basically just named after
their cities but everyone knows DK and
Lans those are the the principal in the
in the donbass region and then I guess
the argument would be KV and Kiev which
is where uh Russian forces and and
attacked from through bellarus Crimea
they want to liberate not defend but I
don't want to be too pedantic Nikki
Haley I don't know how she got those
answers someone rushed to you know did
she like check her phone look down and
be like quick I think face when ask she
she is waiting for the moderator to be
like like and now you speak and that's
not the game V is playing that's not the
game to a certain extent DeSantis is
playing like he said it she didn't even
realize the camera was on her so she's
staring blankly because she's listening
to someone who's standing over there
maybe she does know the region maybe she
doesn't but it was perfectly teed up by
Ras Swami she was not quick enough to
respond that's I think the fact that she
said CIA show she doesn't know what
she's talking about she doesn't it took
her like five minutes to get to it right
she could have said it immediately
instead she was flustered by being
Crimea has been for for a decade under
the control of Russia and and sasap the
Russians have already been there well
before that with their Naval Base so
he's so maybe you can argue she didn't
understand what exct he meant and she
was interpreting as but I'm I'm not
playing that game he immediately called
her out and if it were me I'd be like it
it look first of all I don't actually
care that much about Ukraine my my my
whole position is more align with v of
we should not be uh sending troops over
there and and fortifying this but
immediately I was like wait I'm like
denet and Lans like the that's the news
I I can name those two right now now and
then as for you be president too Tim
yeah the one thing I'm not sure of is I
know those are the names of of the
regions but but I I fact checked they're
basically the names of the Cities so KV
KV those are also the names of the Bel
Deno I'm reading them off map Etc crime
well the funny thing is if you think
about it right so it's like you know we
pull out of Afghanistan in the most
horrible way surrender I you know my
buddy who came with me here who's you
know downstairs right now like he was up
like got no sleep for weeks uh trying to
get guys out right a lot of guys did
right trying to get guys out of there it
was a total disaster and then six months
later you know all the you know the
military industrial complex right they
needed uh new business you know so it's
like Business Development like what do
you know right six months later we got a
new war more money all that you know
like I'm not trying to sound too
conspiratorial but you know it looks
that way yeah when they split up the
Soviet Union and they gave all that land
to you theuk ukine those oligarchs must
have known it was going to cause
contention with Russia down the line not
having access to the Black Sea we don't
call it the Ukraine we call it Ukraine
it is
Borderland yeah you're absolutely true
I'm not I'm I'm no like Eastern European
Russian expert or like but right we it's
like it's like all of a sudden everyone
has to say ke now instead of Kev you
know like come on we spelled zelinsky's
name like three different ways it's just
crazy how many wise P wise maybe more
wise seven wise I think it is worth
noting that ultimately chrisy was right
that it's about Trump more than anything
else uh and it is interesting to watch
the fighting like it's not I think Vegas
is performing well they you know there
have been interesting moments but
ultimately it the question remains how
will anyone stand up if they were to
debate Trump they won't I it shows the
two legitimate candidates is DeSantis
and ramaswami and the other two are like
warhawks that are just kind of on the
trail big money yeah 100% that's like
that's absolutely it and honestly like
you I was saying earlier is like on that
that stage on that stage like Vic's the
guy he's the guy absolutely for for like
normal folks I think he has the Charisma
I mean I think there are questions about
his policies in some respects but I
think he always has been the most
charismatic person in in all of these
debate performances again he does have
the occasional thing you know he said
something like I have a longer future
than Donald Trump he has he has sparred
with Donald Trump very indirectly and
again I wonder what that would look like
if they were up against each other it's
more anecdotal but he's he's humble in
the sense that he was was willing to
come in and and do this interview when
Tim was out of town even though so I
interview and Hannah Clair interviewed
him Sheamus cin and hold on it's worse
than that we had we we we had a
miscommunication here about who was
contacting his team to let him know that
I was at the at a doctor's appointment
not going to be in town and uh so they
found out really late and V was super
cool he like no no don't worry about it
I get it man these things happen
indication to me he will listen to his
advisers like that's a huge important
thing for for leader absolutely but also
the fact that like he'll go talk
anywhere he he he'll go I this is a huge
show huge show but it's like he he goes
on all the podcast it's great thees not
poll show immigration and the crisis are
among the most pressing issues for
Republican voters right now both the
issue of migrants Crossing illegally
into our country and the separate issue
of fenel being smuggled in mostly
through legal ports of Entry all year
news nation has been at the border
documenting the crisis in 2023 alone
border patrol encountered a record news
Nation does a pretty good job Mig all
four of you have talked tough question
now is how realistic is the talk so
Governor Dan santis I'd like to start
with you you have pledged to send the
military to the southern border on day
one of your Administration with orders
to shoot stone cold dead anyone
illegally entering with a backpack that
you believe contains fenel critics have
called this a shoot first ask questions
later policy that would amount to extra
judicial killing you are a former
military lawyer why do you think this
idea of yours would be legal the drug
cartels are invading our country and
they are killing our citizens by the
tens of thousands every year uh we had a
situation in Florida there was an
18-month-old baby that was crawling on
the floor of an a Airbnb rental there
was fenel residue on the carpet and the
baby died is this acceptable in this
country I know the Elites in DC they
don't care they don't care that fentol
is ravaging your community they don't
care that illegal aliens are are
ravaging our community and overwhelming
our community the commander and chief
not only has a right you have a
responsibility to fight back against
these people and does that mean shooting
first it means you're going to you're
going to categorize them as foreign
terrorist organizations uh and we will
identify just like we would anywhere
when I was in Iraq the Iraq the the
al-Qaeda wasn't wearing a uniform you'd
see anyone walking down the street they
all had M dresses on didn't know if
someone had a a bomb an IED attached or
not and so you had to make a judgment
based on intelligence based on positive
identification but we're going to be
able to get the Intelligence on these
cartel people and here's the thing if we
had a wall across the southern border
which I support this would not have
happened we need to build a wall across
the southern border I'll get it done and
I'll make for I Mexico is supposed to
pay for it remember here's how you do
that I am going to have fees on
remittances from foreign workers when
they send the money back to foreign
countries we're going to tax it and
we're going to build the wall with that
so yes you should have had that but we
don't have it I'm G to build it but we
have to lean in on this problem I am not
going to sit there and allow mothers to
lose more kids because of fenol Overdose
I am not going to sit there and let sex
trafficking go unabated or human
trafficking go unabated there's going to
be a new sheriff in town and these drug
cartels nothing disagreeable there
Ambassador haly you have pledged to
catch and
deorta off the system which is it so
first of all what I said is all of the
seven or eight million illegals that
have come under Biden's watch absolutely
have to go back we have to stop the
incentive of what's bringing them over
here in the first place Biden just gave
temporary protective status to 500,000
Venezuelans that's a half a million
social security cards that's a half a
million driver's licenses and I know
from my time at the United Nations the
first thing they do is pick up the phone
and said we came over come on over and
that's what sends more you have to go
and Deport these people so they know it
can't happen again for those that have
been here longer than that we've got to
start seeing who is how long have they
been here have they been vetted paid
taxes have they been working and figure
out who else is out there but what I
know is my parents came here illegally
they put in the time they put in the
price they are offended by those that
are coming illegally we can't let them
skip the line but when you talk about
fentel like you did before let's look at
something else yes I think we should
send Special Operations over and take
out the cartels I think we should do a a
remain in Mexico policy so they never
step foot in US soil in the first place
but look at where fentanyl came from
let's go to the heart of the matter it
came from China that that's why we need
to end all normal trade relations with
China until they stop murdering
Americans with fentanyl I promise you
they need our economy they will
immediately stop that but this is where
Trump went wrong Trump was good on trade
but that's all he was with China because
here he allowed fentanyl to continue to
come over he continued to allow them to
take he would give them technology that
would build up their military and hurt
us he allowed the Chinese infiltration
for them to buy up Farmland to put money
in our universities and to continue to
do things that were harmful for America
we now have a spy Base in Cuba and
police stations and Trump didn't do
anything about thank you thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net